start slicing sirloin steak into strips  then simply marinate in soy sauce the  salty and runny honey the sweet and  leave up to 2 hours then thread your  marinated beef strips onto skewers and  pan fry in hot olive oil for the topping  which add the lovely sour contrasts  break carrot and simply lead to pickle  in rice vinegar  next make the easy dressing simply  decedent chop a Chile and castor sugar  and lime juice add a glug of fish sauce  sliced up forget when lovely and brown  the marinated steak skewers are done  remove and add top with the pickled  carrot add cool sliced cucumber drizzle  over the spicy dressing and to finish it  off add coriander leaves  it's simple to make but complex in  flavor absolutely delicious  take your knife keep it nice and flat on  the board and sort of slice it in half  okay sort of scholar that's a rolling  boil the secret there it stops the pass  from sticking together and it gently  rolls it around